what's going on guys today we're going
to examine what the future likely holds
for derby
after he finally revealed his identity
in my academia
chapter 219. we'll be talking about how
his relevance might change after this
arc
and predict what his next moves will
likely be going forward
as you can expect there will be spoilers
ahead so uh proceed with caution
and as usual don't forget to hit that
sub button if you haven't already
okay so for the longest time the most
intriguing thing about darby
has been the secret surrounding his
identity so much so that
in the official ultra analysis book the
highest rated stat for this character
was mystery now that we know for a fact
he is toyotaroki
aka the son of the number one hero what
exactly will be his defining role from
now on
personally i think dabi's actions over
the coming years
will now serve to directly build him up
to be
shoto's final enemy for the end of
mahira academia
we've already seen that he feels no
brotherly love towards the youngest
todoroki
and in fact dabi once thought about
killing shoto according to the spoilers
for the latest chapter
therefore i think it's likely that
harakoshi will create this direct
rivalry
between toya and shoto similar to the
one that exists between deku and
shiguraki
there are two main ways i see this
happening with the first and most
obvious
being that toya kills endeavour during
the war arc
since the beginning of the war endeavour
has fought the regular nomu he's fought
the higher nomu
obviously he fought against shigaraki
and then he fought against all for one
who was
kind of like possessing shiguraki's body
so he's been through a lot he's pretty
exhausted
and he's basically at his limit at this
moment
endeavour just doesn't have it in him to
put up a genuine fight
whereas dabi on the other hand he's
looking fresher than ever before
this situation was foreshadowed back in
the pro hero arc
in which endeavor was exhausted from his
fight with the hyena mu
and then debbie rushed in to attack him
seemingly not caring that the fight was
totally unfair
on that occasion mirko kind of
intervened to stop darby
but i mean this time around he has a
second chance to attack his father while
he's down
if toya kills the number one hero in the
upcoming chapters
it would not only scar shoto for life
but it would also give him motivation
to get revenge on his older brother i
think it's important to remember
that shoto has not yet told his dad that
he forgives him
so in my opinion this is something i
would like to see it would be kind of
poetic
if shoto was to say he forgives his dad
as like
kind of like final words to endeavor
right before the hero gets just
fried by his oldest son it would show
that ng did do enough to redeem himself
in the eyes of one child but that the
past still came back to bite him it
would be
pretty poetic and sad but you know it'd
also be like an epic moment for this
series so
this is the this is the ideal scenario
for me the chaos that toya has now
created
will surely make stains will a reality
and the so-called fake heroes
will no longer be revered by society
because toya is the one who exposed the
heroes
it's possible that he can gain a
following similar to how stayne did
the fact remains that stain was a
murderer but you know
even students like deku and seji they
understood
or respected his ideology um so i do
think debbie could gain a following
for being the one to expose the heroes
and essentially
all the followers of stain will now
follow darby i should also mention that
darby's broadcast to japan
makes him seem like the victim so i
think a lot of people will be very
sympathetic towards him
and be willing to follow him as one of
the leaders of the paranormal liberation
front
debbie can use his position of authority
and also his potential army of
supporters
to acquire power wealth and also
quirks if you've not seen my dabby
regeneration theory
then i'd recommend checking it out but
the basic idea
is that shiguraki can use all for one to
give dabi new quirks such as
regeneration
and of course dr garagi can enhance
toya's body to
handle multiple quirks but i i guess
first they have to get him back from the
heroes
which shouldn't be too much of a problem
with toya having two quirks
and shoto having a hybrid quirk the
parallel between them would become
even more obvious and so i think it's
something that hirokoshi might consider
moving on though whether endeavour is
killed or not
the fact is that toya has now totally
destroyed his career
public popularity is a big factor when
it comes to where hiro's place on the
rankings
and thanks to toya's broadcast everyone
knows the truth about endeavour's
terrible past
even endeavours fans were watching the
broadcast this move will definitely
crumble any faith that there would have
been
for heroes in japan i mean if you're a
japanese citizen how can you feel
safe when not only is the son of the
number one hero a villain
but giganto makia and sugaraki were
allowed to run rampage and take
thousands of lives to be honest there
will be no trust left
which brings us to this second way that
harakoshi can create
a direct rivalry between the todoroki
brothers
dabi knows that ua is one of the biggest
foundations of hero society
and so naturally he'll do anything he
can to destroy people's trust
in ua in the aftermath of this entire
arc
i think that ua might be shut down and
students will be forced to flee abroad
the reason i think this is possible is
because ua has put students on the front
line
of a war and dabby mentioned himself how
he thought this was a bit tacky
how is bakugo's mom going to react when
she sees has been
literally skewered on live tv and how is
inca midoriya going to react
when she sees that deku is i mean deku's
just being deku
but you know it's going to be bad for
the parents as well they won't want
their children
attending ua if the school does shut
down
then it will only cause chauter's
resentment to grow
because as we all know his dream is to
become a hero
and by the school shutting down it's
kind of like a massive obstacle
by fleeing abroad the youngest todoroki
would have no choice but to get
much stronger before he can return and
face the enhanced
toyotaroki this could parallel how deku
needs to unlock all the different quirks
before he can return to face the
enhanced shigaraki
ultimately those were just some of the
ideas i had in the aftermath of the
toyotaroki reveal
but i think they're all plausible based
on what we've seen so far
let me know what you think might happen
next in the comments below
and remember that i'm streaming tomorrow
and on sunday
at midday eastern time until the next
one
peace out